Stephanie Bertram is the press secretary
over at the White House she joins us
tonight to clarify a point that as some
of us confused Stephanie thanks so much
for coming on tonight is impeachment
going on has the president been
impeached has he not what's gonna happen
what is this I mean it's it continues to
be a crazy sham it continues to be
something that I don't think any of us
understand you know the great thing
about this whole thing is that when she
Nancy Pelosi goes low our poll numbers
keep going high so that's a fantastic
thing I think that the people that that
are leading this this crazy effort Nancy
Pelosi and Schumer and the likes of them
they're gonna go down in history as the
people who weaponized impeachment and
this is going to go on for years and
years to come other presidents can now
get impeached over policy disputes so
we'll see what happens she's got to get
it over there to the Senate because then
obviously the impeachment isn't gonna be
valid it's not gonna be legitimate in
the eyes of the American people and once
it does go to the Senate it will be
exactly what we've been saying on a rat
all along the president did absolutely
nothing wrong right but as it is I mean
in the holding pattern where it remains
it seems to be if anything helping the
president in his reelect so are you
anxious to get it to the Senate is the
status quo hurting you do you think no I
would say that it's you know the
president has said over and over again
that he would like to get it to the
Senate I don't think anybody wants to
have the word impeachment attached to
their presidency and he has said that a
few times so of course we would like it
to go to the Senate so that we can show
that he did nothing wrong we can you
know push back on all of the lies that
they were telling in the house and I
want to say the irony that they are
holding these articles after you know
because they're worried about fairness
and the sentence is just it's it's
ironic it's the hypocrisy abounds it
continues to be a she's just I don't
know what she's thinking I think she's
stuck I think she doesn't know what to
do actually yes I think I actually I
think what you just said is apps I think
that's absolutely right she's caught
between warring factions and she's stuck
I agree Stephanie great DC tonight
thanks so much for coming on thank you
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas